foreign
good morning
ready
we will now open up the public hearing
on Senate Bill 49 and recognize the
prime sponsor Senator Tim Lang welcome
to Ways and Means thank you members of
ways and means and again this is still
my favorite committee you can tell by
how much time I'm spending here and I'm
still a state senator as as I was
earlier
um this bill in front of you Senate Bill
49 is a pretty straightforward bill it
came out of a study committee that
representative ulrey and I served on
from last year in Senate Bill 330 that
looked at oplc there were three bills
that were generated out of that study
committee this being one of them
um the idea was as many of you know that
we have that 125 percent rule relative
to fees that are charged that would not
allow that we're supposed to recover our
costs and up to and 25 more but not more
than that or the the Supreme Court's
rule that it's a tax versus a fee and so
in oplc we ran into the issue where uh
licensing fees that we were covering
were exceeding the amount of expenditure
and we were elapsing money back into the
general fund so in 2019 we lapsed 3.4
million in 2000 2020 we lapsed three
thousand a 3.3 million twenty one we
lapsed 4.1 and this year we lapsed where
uh we allowed well in 22 was 2.6 so
every year we're lapsing monies back to
the general fund but the idea behind a
fee is that it's supposed to go to serve
the person who paid the fee and this is
going to general fund Monies to use for
whatever this legislature decides and
not the person who paid the fee so the
idea behind this bill is to make sure
that fees go back to help the person
paying the fee in this case the
licensees so that if this if the agency
collects more money than an anticipator
that will use any excess money to lower
the cost of licenses not to just fund
the general fund so that's the short
version of the bill the how the Senate
amended this my original Bill to add a
reporting requirement the idea that we
had when when I put this bill forward
was that I was expecting the commission
of oplc to put basically a 10-year plan
out right is that this is what we expect
to kind of spend money on in the next 10
years and so just like in all of our
cities towns school districts we have
capital reserve funds that we put money
in because we know we've got a roofing
project or something like that that the
idea this Reserve fund would bet they
would be able to slowly build upon if
they knew they were going to be doing a
large multi-million dollar expenditure
or even smaller projects million dollar
expenditures but over the next five or
six years they could plan for those
expenditures and not create spiking in
fees where all of a sudden they've got
to do an Erp uh enterprise resource
planning upgrade software upgrade that's
a five million dollar bump and because
they're self-funded they've got to go
raise everybody's fees to cover the five
million dollars we didn't want to do
that where we create a spike in the fee
and then we drop it back down so the
idea was to create this non-lapsing fund
to allow them put money in identify
their 10-year plan and then execute use
this funding for that 10-year plan
without having to affect licensures and
then also recognize that anything that
wasn't needed for the 10-year plan would
be used to lower licensure fees so that
was the bill the Senate added the
reporting requirement the house out of
the cap I'm not a great fan of the cap
um I I again my my I would like to see
the director be able to put a 10-year
plan together
um and say that this is how we expect we
might be using some of these funds that
would define the cap and then if we
wanted to come back and put a cap on
after she's had the opportunity to do
that I think that would be smart but the
house chose to put the three million
dollar cap on which is I think what you
did with your version of this bill as
well but I my preference is not to have
a cap and at least give the director the
opportunity to put a 10-year plan
together that will stabilize the license
fees
thank you very much would you be open to
questions absolutely representative
yeah Andrew Kimmy please Senator Lang we
have a house bill that does the same
thing I think you tabled it oh did we
okay thanks
representative Elber
thank you madam chair uh and thank you
for taking the question
um I'm curious about whether
we are consistent whether this
um
bill and the idea of returning funds to
lowering licensing fees is consistent or
different from other Industries for
example liquor The Liquor Commission if
they have excess do they use it to lower
licensing fees so thank you for the
question so again I'm not sure that
liquor has any licensing fees but what
liquor does do is they are again a
self-funded agency so they pay for their
own buildings and they pay for their own
so again when they build out a brand new
building to I'll use the example in
Tilton right that's built a brand new
building a couple years ago right that
that long-term bond that long-term
mortgage is paid for added liquor fees
because they're a self-funded agency so
I don't believe liquor has any licensing
fees that they could turn back to a
taxpayer it's all done but liquor also
manages the price of liquor in the state
of New Hampshire and so they help you
know as as you can tell by the latest
report which said that New Hampshire has
the highest liquor per capita in the
nation um they seem to do a pretty good
uh
they do a pretty good job at managing
pricing to encourage people to buy here
in the state
follow up follow thank you and I'm
wondering if this is more for us rather
than for Senator Lang
are there any other situations where
there are licensing fees and would are
there would there be parallel situations
with those groups where excess funds are
returned
as uh lowering those fees or would all
of those fees stay in the general fund
I don't know yeah I can tell you that
lots of agencies have licensing fees
liquor definitely does I can tell you
for sure
um and they stay in liquor this is
different this is a unique situation
this is the oplc so this is the office
of professional licensure so this is a
different category so none of the others
that I'm aware of go back to the general
fund
that you
let's I'll just throw that out on the
liquor side and I saw some hands over
here first of all representative Oliver
yours is up
thank you madam chair
um so if I if I'm if I'm reading this
correctly the difference is that the
house bill did not have
um
the reporting requirement and the house
bill did not have a split cap on
dividing it's uh three and let's say for
our show was set at five let's say two
just for numbers uh so we split it up in
that fish is that correct
so if I my understanding is um so you're
right on the reporting requirement and
the second aspect was there was a cap
put in the house but again anything over
the cap went to the general fund this
specifies that anything over the cap
must be used to lower
fees
so follow up Madam chair follow-up
so you're using the three million
dollars for Capital Improvements in
Investments and anything left over that
so that if the uh agent LPL PLC
um spends one million dollars on a new
computer software upgrade whatever
overpriced but just numbers
um for that that would leave two million
of the three million of the cap and they
do all of that money
would then also go towards reducing the
fees because it would go back into the
operating budget of the oplc which would
then reduce the fees before anything
went to the general fund
so in this model in the model in this
bill the way the Senate Edna and the how
cdna modified the bill no money ever
goes to the general fund in this bill
there's a three million dollar cap that
they can hold after by at the end of the
biennium if there's more than three
million dollars they've received rather
than expended then they could hold that
three million dollars they can choose
not to they can only hold two million
and say we're gonna put a million
dollars back into lowering fees too
nothing requires them to hit the cap
before they do that but they're allowed
to keep up to three million dollars in
in there for long-term planning be able
to do your Capital expenditures and
anything that is over that so
um let's say they brought in 3.5 million
dollars so they kept the three million
dollars and a half a million dollars
that they have left they would be
required under this bill to take that
half a million dollars and lower
licensing fees over the next biennium by
half a million dollars for our nurses
and our electricians and plumbers and
all the people who get a uh oplc license
one more follow-up so
choose your
3.5 so you now get 500 000 goes into
reducing fees that would be applied and
this is would be probably be a question
for the uh uh oplc administrative staff
as to how is that going to be divided up
equally or where to set up in their
operating rules in some fashion yeah I
that's a little gray right now so again
having having served on that committee
with you what we learned was that each
board
is basically assigned a cost for lack of
interface how much how much
administrative time they use it's a pro
rated cost based on the entire cost of
oplc
um they're they're assigned a cost and
from that cost is what they Define
licensure from so my expectation I'm
sure the commission will correct me if
I'm wrong is that if there's a half a
million dollars left over that would be
prorated to each board based on the the
fee that would be charged to them for
running that board to buy oplc
that makes sense I'm not sure if that
got a little confusing but no
no
if I'm correct is the key word on that
representative almi
thank you
um boy a number of things about this on
the
you're defining as capital expenditures
purchase of software is that normally
considered to be
a capital expense
I I actually sometimes yes my apologize
could you restate the question
um is is purchase of software which is
the only major expense that is left it
seems to me on a capital expense
so again I think capital expenditure is
usually defined by a dollar amount I'm
not sure what the dollar amount in the
state of New Hampshire is I think it's
for the purposes of like just a contract
with the with the executive Council
isn't it five thousand dollars anything
over a five thousand dollar expenditure
would have to go outside and go to a
separate separate expenditure so
um would go in front of the uh so I
would I would view this at an uh
especially because then they have a
hundred and some odd employees that
something like an Erp uh uh planning
process a customer service process that
allows them documentation you're talking
a multi-million dollar project having
been in the technology industry I can
tell you that a software upgrade for an
Erp system for 100 users is probably
going to run you in the range of three
to five million dollars so this would
allow them to be able to use that
depending on if it's a full replacement
just a minor upgrade or just a tweak but
um that kind of we're talking about
again serious money
and yeah and that particular one the the
software industry to my distress has on
moved to doing subscriptions rather than
purchases
and quite frequently they only they
require that you do it that way and I
understood uh from her testimony before
that uh on they are looking at doing
those software upgrades as subscriptions
which would even out the money over the
years so again it would talk about
whether you purchase or or SAS software
as a service model but even in a
software as a service model when you
make changes to the base model so you
can buy a piece of software I did this
for I worked in the healthcare
Information Technology electronic
medical record systems and so when you
do a change for a given office so if
oplc wants a workflow a certain way and
they want to modify that workflow that's
not covered under your monthly
subscription it's still going to be an
additional cost to do that customized
workflow process which will still be
again if you're affecting 100 users in
100 different version uh 100 computer
systems that upgrade could be
multi-million dollar upgrade depending
on what the nature of the change is
that's outside the out of the box
software
thank you
Ames did I see your hand up
I think I took it down thank you uh
other representative fellows
um yes ma'am cheer um I I have a list of
questions so
my my first question has to do with just
the bill I looked at it and and I
couldn't when I when I tried to figure
out like what does the bill currently
say now so take out you know the
crossouts I couldn't put together a
whole sentence there kind of in the
middle of the first paragraph So I
looked back I went to the rsas and
looked at them and this this bill is not
drafted correctly
because the language like the part shall
be used for Capital expenditures like
that part of it's not in the current RSA
and unless I'm missing something
um I actually comment on that a little
bit just the reason why representative
McGuire the chairman of Edna tabled our
bill is because she's working on another
big piece of this which is re-codifying
everything
so there is going to be some changing
RSA numbers
so that's why you may not be seeing it
anywhere because there's other moving
parts
so
so are you saying that this bill is
irrelevant because it's going to show up
in another bill I believe not I believe
the other bill is going to be more of
redesigning the structure of oplc and
this is more just on the
how much money can they hold on so my
comment is about the drafting because
what I see here this is not
the um the first sections is not that
what it currently says in statute
so that that's a concern because we
can't really vote on it because
representative Platt has had his hand
waving over here so look you're okay
with that okay representative ulery yeah
so are you are you responding to my
comment yes please the way
I think some of the confusion is this
bill was modified in the modifications
are the ones that are being shown not
new language
this entire thing could be in just plain
if it was to replace the entire thing
so whatever language shows up in here
is going to go into law whether it's
there now or not no
so anyway I think I you know maybe you
would need to check on that okay I mean
I do understand and we can you know I
have questions about the intent but I
think that there's an issue with the
drafting I would just remind folks that
we are the second committee on this so
we are not discussing the underlying
policy as much as really focusing on the
non-lapsing nature of the fund the cap
on the fund that's really our Focus just
keep that in mind
so again Senate Bill House Bill 350 655
I think it is for 355 camera which which
numbers but that was the oplc bill that
again came out of the commission that uh
representative ulry and I served on from
Senate Bill 355 which does
huge modification to oplc but not around
this topic so we divided the we divided
the in the study commission we divided
three changes that were required this
was one of the three Senate bills House
Bill 355 representative McGuire's bill I
think it is
um was the was the big policy change and
then it was one other one I drawn a
blank on what that one was
so but there were three policy changes
this one speak to to the Chairman's
point this one is specifically about
what happens to the lapses and the fact
that the lapse needs should go to serve
the people that paid the fee to begin
with and to make sure that we use that
to keep the costs as low as possible for
the licenses licenses that we issue so
so that was so so I told you about my
first concern so my second concern is
that
from the um your testimony it it occurs
to me that we wouldn't be having this
bill if the fees currently did not give
the um the agency a surplus that was so
big is the one as the ones that we're
we're getting because that current loss
is the
they're not supposed to be generating
more Revenue than 125 percent of what it
costs to operate
so
obviously the fees are too cumulative
fees are too high now
and
um I
you and I since we're both on gel car
you may have looked at something that's
coming up for the next meeting that had
actually had several pages that
identified all the different fees for
all of them and clearly some to me in my
mind some were like too high and some
were too low but can you tell me
what plans are in the works and how how
would would the agency go about
determining what the accurate
um what appropriate
bees would be as opposed to what's in
there now sure so so understand that
oplc has
defense to the commissioner she's been
trying to hit a moving Target because
the legislature keeps changing it and
she's trying to shoot at it hit it right
and so I think she's doing the right
things again we see that in 2002 the
number dramatically reduced right it
went from 4.1 million in 2001 and then
they made some changes and it went down
to 2.6 million so it dropped dropped
over a million 1.5 million dollars do
you mean 2021 from 2021 to 2022 it
dropped by 1.5 million dollars Surplus
reduction because they adjusted into
doing so they're trying trying to
correct and not have a dramatic Surplus
um and so I I think they're doing a
great job but again it's a moving Target
we just like I said House Bill 355 is
gonna or 655 whatever that number is is
going to dramatically change stuff again
for them
um but I think they're doing a great job
at trying to keep this Surplus down but
in the event there is a surplus that
what this build really says is it's not
general fund money to go for Allstate
for the entire state it should go back
and be used for the purposes of the
people who paid those fees in alignment
with the superior the Supreme Court
decision of 125 percent and anything
above that is
um consider the tax and be unfair tax
representative
yes I'm curious uh Senator Lang what's
your problem with the cap
well again I'd like to I I don't I don't
work in oplc so I don't know what their
plans are for the next 10 years as they
look at this and so I'd like to give the
commission the opportunity to put a plan
together to find out whether or not
um you know just like I said our schools
and towns know we've got to replace a
roof on a building and so we may put
aside 250 000 a year of undesignated
fund balance a year for five six years
to pay for a multi-million dollar roof
on a Town building or a school rather
than have that all hit in one year and
jump the local tax rate up and so I'd
like to you know my opinion was I
trusted the commissioner not to be able
to put a 10-year type plan together and
understand what that looks like and
manage that fund and do an a biannual
report and if the legislature doesn't
like what it sees it can go put a cap on
it but at least give their first
opportunity for not having a cap to let
her put it put a plan together
you still open to more
quickly you are today representative
elberger
thank you madam chair first just a quick
comment about
subscriptions while
it may be easier to spread cost over
time the amount you're paying for
something is almost invariably
significantly higher than if you do an
outright purchase
and having gotten that off my chest I
want to look at the other end
um
what this Bill is saying is that there's
a recognition that fees are too high or
may be too high and when they are
determined to be too high then the fees
would be reduced I'm wondering about the
reverse if it gets to be a situation
where the fees are not covering the
costs
is
it understood that the fees could be
increased I don't see any language about
that in here so again that's a different
part of the law so two things could
happen in that case so in the event that
they lowered fees and then they ended up
not taking enough Revenue in to cover
the cost of oplc they could also use
this fun to supplement that and to make
sure that the fund was whole and that we
didn't have a deficit in that agency so
it could be used to supplant
underperforming it licensors
um
so I
so that to I guess I'm not sure if I
understand the second half of your
question the second part of your
question so the question
um if I may
um
what happens if it gets to a point where
there is not enough in the fund
to cover costs
without increasing fees is it understood
at that point that while
that oplc has the option to both lower
and raise thank you for the question so
again in in that house bill 355 365 650
right whatever that number is
um I will say one of the things that we
were cleaning up and we learned what
representative ulry and I learned in
that in that um committee was that we
have conflicting law and we were trying
to look at cleaning it up we have places
where the oplc director has the right to
set licensing fees and then we also give
that same exact right to a board and the
board has a right to set fees I don't
know what happens if we have conflict
between those two but the purpose of one
of the purposes of that house bill was
to clean up that conflict in law so the
oplc director or the board uh under
current law already has the right to
raise and lower prices so we don't need
to give that the question is if if the
price is such that we end up with for
some reason the giant Surplus what we do
with that we want to make sure it goes
back to pay back to the licensees thank
you thank you madam
okay other questions for Senator Lane
keeping in mind uh I have no other pink
cards but we might have an expert in the
audience so representative homie yes I
think I'll Reserve most of my questions
for that but we are
um
establishing a new precedent here
um we did not have a precedent for 125
percent for all fees before this time
and we are now creating that on I had a
run in with the Comptroller a year after
she arrived on in that dedicated fund
committee on in which on she insisted
that since the legislature had put it
into law that we were going to um
have a set fee for a particular thing
that has nothing to do with this agency
um that and lapse the rest of it at the
end of the year and they were routinely
lapsing 75 of what the fee was
to the general fund on that the
legislative uh decision stood and the
125 percent that the finance committee
was using in the budget
for a number of purposes was not a
general
law so we're we're making this a law now
for oplc
that they all do that and then we do run
into the problem that there are a couple
of Agents of groups that are licensed or
or put into PLC
in earlier days I think the manufactured
housing was put in
when we started is there a question for
the senator yes and the question
is do you recognize this is going on and
and why are we doing this before we
get representative McGuire's complete
overhaul of the entire system
thank you for your question number one
you did get representative McGuire's you
voted on already in the house it's
already in the Senate Edna committee so
you've already passed it
um and it's over it's over in the uh
Senate Edna and they're working if my
understanding is
um that bill is going to be passed
unamended and and be done
um to answer your other question there's
no conversation here about 125 percent
right you know that percentage is not
anywhere in here all's we're saying is
we want to keep license fees for our
citizens as low as possible to be able
to cover the cost of lplc not great a
giant Surplus and if we do create a
giant Surplus we wanted to go back to
the citizens who are paying for those
fees that's what this bill is
establishing in law
thank you other questions for the
senator representative fellow um yeah
this is just technical
um I I thought I was looking at the rsas
last night and I thought I saw that 125
percent in there somewhere well again
it's just not in this bill like we're
not established and press it in this
bill it may be in law somewhere else
already in statute maybe can you just
tell me about the two bills you were
taught you've talked about two bills
other than this one one is one got
tabled in the house and one is now in
um over in the Senate that are related
to this well what I'll say is the only
it's related in the fact that when we
had the committee that
um to look at oplc and the issues within
oplc we came out with three
recommendations
um and I and I believe
um
I don't remember one of them I'm drawing
a complete blank I apologize I didn't
prepare for that for reading back that
committee but
um representative ulrey and I both took
took uh this aspect which was the money
because we knew it was going to go in
front of ways and means so we Cho we we
agreed to submit the um this bill
um the other bill was Edna related
relative to the operations of oplc and
therefore uh representative McGuire
agreed to take on that bill
um that bill and I apologize I don't
remember the number but that bill that's
currently in the Senate DNA
um is already been voted on by the house
and you've already seen it it's already
been seen and voted on by the house and
passed if I want to say it was passed on
consent
um but I don't recall
thank you Senator
um thank you thank you
oh well I I had a question
for the senator for the oplc I for I
think for the senator because there is
nobody here yet from lbao
uh to answer this why do we have a zero
fiscal note when it is clear that uh
they are going to reduce the lapse to
the general fund by 6.5 to 8 million
dollars at the end of next year
as an LBA question I honestly don't know
why on the fiscal note they didn't
assign a dollar figure or maybe the
commissioner could answer that question
yeah the commissioner actually is the
one that produced the information so
maybe she can
thank you for accepting all these
questions if I had to make a guess just
to say it's because we don't actually
reduce any fees or funds we just change
the allocation on where it goes so the
state doesn't see less Revenue it just
sees a change in the allocation of the
fund
thank you very much
I apologize I'm not sure if are you a
commissioner or director
director welcome uh thank you for
filling out a pin card thank you for
coming up
could you please introduce introduce
yourself for the uh committee and if you
wouldn't mind if you can answer any of
these questions that would be helpful
certainly thank you madam chair members
of the committee Lindsey Courtney I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire office of professional
licensure and certification and I wish
to thank Senator Lang for bringing this
bill forward oplc fully supports
um this bill
um I wanted to start by addressing some
of the questions specifically around the
oplc Surplus
so
the the cause of the Surplus is really
twofold first up until last session over
half the practice acts had fees set
forth in statute and as all of you know
we have no ability to change fees that
are in statute
um generally those fees were either 300
or a hundred and ten dollars
um generally the 300 fees were way above
125 and 110 was a little bit below the
um the 125 Mark
um we had tried consistently since 2019
to seek legislation to remove those
statutory fees
um
2019 we we sought legislation 2020 2021
it wasn't until 2022 that we are
successful
then in 2022 we announced uh that we
were going to start soliciting feedback
from our boards and stakeholders as to
what the fees should be it was at that
point that a few stakeholders were
became concerned that oplc had fee
setting authority to begin with which
dated back to 2015 actually which
generated a lot of uh
comments and stakeholder participation I
think it was before Senate Ways and
Means so at that point in time we were
asked by the governor's office to put a
pause on modifying our fees and
representative fellows The Proposal that
you are referencing that's going for
jail car does not
um with several minor exceptions does
not include any changes to fees that
have been in existence for years
so that is one reason why we have a
surplus which is that many of the fees
were statutory other fees were
established by boards for years
um boards themselves are not responsible
for paying the bills and you know I I
would venture to say that many of the
fees were to some extent arbitrary
many of our boards are not covering
their costs um I would say that
barbering and cosmetology for example
covers about 40 percent of their costs
they have not had fee changes uh with
the exception of one minor fee change
last year to raise the cost of their fee
by ten dollars they have not had fee
changes in years
and one of the concerns we have in the
office is how do you increase fees
dramatically because the board neglected
to raise fees incrementally over the
course of the years so these are the
changes and the issues that we're
grappling with as we talk about how to
level set the fees for the boards the
number two reason why we have a surplus
is because when
um revenues State revenues are up and
things are going well the city has money
to pay for its expenditures when
revenues are not up uh state agencies
are directed to cut costs and we were
directed to cut costs back in 2019 2020
-2019 2020 and what was called a Labs
Target
meaning that we lapse significantly more
than we would have liked to cover our
operating expenses
the concern I have with the cap is that
does not
um that does not eliminate that
possibility from occurring by virtue of
the fact that we would propose to Labs
funds to the general fund
um we are subject to having
um you know directives to essentially
cut expenditures so that we can lapse
more into the general fund to cover
general fund operating expenses
and I would just note that the committee
which was a bipartisan committee found
that Surplus fees Beyond agency
expenditures are lapsed into the general
fund the lapsing of these funds does not
serve any purpose for the licensee and
only serves to continually drive up fees
the Surplus is not the only area where
fees are concerned
so
um we we can certainly work within a cap
because I think a cap is better than
nothing but
um but the purpose of licensure fees is
to fund licensure operations and and
that's it it is not to fund other parts
of state government or the general fund
and that is what's happening
um the other thing that I wish to
mention is that unlike other Revenue
generating self-funded agencies like
liquor and Lottery we are not a revenue
generating Agency on July 1 we have we
have no no money
um on June 30th uh the large portion of
our renewal cycle ends and this year
unless we have some statutory change all
of our funds will lapse to the general
fund and we will have zero dollars on
July one
it doesn't mean that we have zero
expenses underly one so this is another
reason why we at least least need a
buffer because our renewal Cycles are
not consistent we have major renewal
Cycles in June of every year and in
December and then throughout the year we
receive initial applications and some
renew like nursing and real estate
consistently
um and it's difficult to project our
Revenue because some of our revenue is
impacted by the market when the housing
is is doing really well we see a huge
influx in real estate applications
because people want to enter that field
um during covid we saw a significant
increase in the number of healthcare
professionals seeking licensure here by
endorsement but it's it's difficult to
project how many licensing applications
we will receive and therefore difficult
to project revenue and that's why it
does not make sense to have the oplc
operate on um you know starting with
zero dollars on July one of a biennium
um
I'd be happy to answer any other
questions I'm sure you have some other
questions with respect to the fiscal
note that is exactly right uh we don't
see a change in in the amount of monies
um to the state it's just a change in in
where those um those funds go
but that would be happy to answer any
questions representative Platt I can't
resist for Barbara cosmetology you're
going to ask some particular haircut
apologize representative all me
Madam chair on well two things I hope
that we could get Chris Shea to come and
talk to us about that fiscal note
before we finish this hearing and um he
just walked in
and the second is
um
there is on a
major question that involves money that
apparently is being dealt with or maybe
it's not being dealt with in the bill
that is going is sitting in the Senate
now that the Ways and Means Committee
didn't see uh
about the um
the fact that we've got I don't know how
many agencies that are
groups that are being are underfunding
their costs uh some of them because the
people in them don't get paid very much
and can't really afford the higher
higher costs
uh and others which are paying way too
much
and also you mentioned plumbers someone
mentioned plumbers and I think aren't
the plumbers still under safety or did
you manage to grab them
um yes they were they were transferred
over us I wouldn't call it a grab
but yes they were transferred over to us
at the last budget cycle
representative Southworth
cosmetology
so will passage of this bill help you to
address that issue
so I think what helped us to address
that issue
um it's really just the large package
that was the result of the study
committee established by 3 30.
um because although we've had statutory
Authority and a statutory directive
since 2015 to establish fees we have not
had stakeholder consensus and that's
part of the problem with oplc generally
is that it was created as part of a
budget cycle nobody wanted us to exist
and that continued to persist for years
and there's still a group of
stakeholders that would like to see the
board set fees I think that's largely
been worked out by now and so our
initial jail car filing that will
hopefully be adopted fairly soon is to
just codify all existing fees in one um
one document and then starting July 1 we
are going to be instituting with the
advice of Bureau of accounts some time
tracking analysis through our New
Hampshire first portal so that we can
appropriately allocate administrative
costs back to the boards and provide a
recommendation as to what we need to do
to increase fees to represent
representative almi's Point regarding
um whether or not we should be
subsidizing certain professions who may
or may not make that much money or
our understanding based on the
legislation is we don't have statutory
authority to do that and we're not
seeking that statutory Authority follow
up follow up so these changes are moving
you in the right direction yes certainly
representative thank you
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um just logistically um you said on July
1st your fund balance goes to zero so
how are you paying bills in July or
August for that matter
yeah so we're I mean we're allowed to
to pay Personnel costs we're allowed to
go in the rad for a person lcos
um so typically by by August uh we have
enough funds to start covering our our
regular
um
expenses if you will but we don't
um we don't seek contracts out you know
typically in the August September time
frame
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chair the way I read the
bill
it essentially creates a four-tier
a pecking order for the use of funds
please confirm this if if I'm
understanding it correctly
so basically when fees uh are derived
they go first to paying costs and
salaries
correct and then as the bill says any
remaining funds
shall be used for Capital expenditures
yes and then the bill goes on to say
that you can keep up to three million
dollars
I guess it's a reserve and then fourth
any funds in excess of the three million
dollar cap
shall be used to reduce licensing and
certification fees and as Senator Lang
said you could
deploy those for reductions before you
reach the cap but you must deploy them
for reductions once you've reached the
Gap correct is that all correct yeah put
that cap just as well be one million
I think the cap could definitely be one
million I think when we talk about
oplc's budget a million dollars is not
significant after all it's already not
only met the operating costs and
salaries it's also been available for
Capital expenditures before it even
starts to accumulate
well the way I read this is that the
capital expenditures could only be up to
three million dollars because the
capital expenditures has to reside
somewhere and so that would have to be
in a dedicated account
and I think that's the issue from our
perspective uh software typically the
last time the state procured software is
in the 3.7 million dollar range there
was a significant amount of some for um
some of uh funding for development work
and likely we will need to amend that to
increase it but there are other Capital
expenditures that I think could be in
excess of a million dollars and
three million dollars so if I can just
clarify
um you are saying that the allowance for
retaining up to 3 million is
specifically for the purpose of covering
Capital expenditures
and I understand Capital expenditures
going back to what was raised before as
being essentially those that involve
more than the current
uh year something that is expended or
has a life cycle of more than one year
correct the way I'm reading this and I
could be wrong but the way we would
interpret it in the office is that we
have our operation our operational
expenses which are approved by the house
and the Senate and the governor GNC
contracts and the like and that anything
in excess we currently retain in our
operating accounts
um and we we could do that up to three
million dollars for the purpose of
capital expenditures but anything beyond
that we would not be able to retain past
the biennium is how I read that
representative Olney
thank you and actually it as I read it
on if at the end of the biennium you
keep three million dollars you have
until the end of the next biennium to
spend six million
if you had a major software purchase
that had to be made or something like
that I I appreciate the reading of that
I don't think we would interpret it to
be that way I mean um
I I think the the
I think the intent is clear that that
anything in excess of three million
we're supposed to use to reduce
licensing fees something that we support
that said we can only reduce licensing
fees if we're requiring others to
actually increase their licensing fees
so the one the one thing I want to leave
this committee with is that there are
some
um uh professions that are paying well
in advance of what they should be paying
and then there are some that are not
paying nearly enough and so that's
that's part of what we're grappling with
in the office
um but I would read the intent of this
legislation and I think that's
consistent with the discussions at the
by the Senate um committee is that we
should be reducing licensing fees
Beyond 3 million
follow up are you tackling the question
of the groups that are being licensed
that um
include people who are earning very
little money
and
if you have to increase the cost of the
licenses a lot of them may drop out of
whatever it is
so
um here are my thoughts on that
um
under the 125 analysis which is
presently in statute
um each profession or each regulatory
board has to support its own costs
anything above 125 percent is considered
an unconstitutional tax
so essentially by lowering fees let's
say for a profession for barbering at 40
percent
you're asking another profession to
subsidize the cost of another profession
our current statutory framework does not
allow that because that would be
considered a tax and so I think it would
be up to the legislature to make that
determination as to whether certain
professions should be subsidizing other
professions but at present that's not
part of our analysis
representative what yes I have a serious
question this time when you uh go into
deficit July and August how deep a
deficit
I would have to bring those numbers back
to you representative
that was aimed at questioning whether 3
million was enough too much whatever
three million is certainly enough to
cover any sort of deficit in July and
August
I just remind the committee that we've
already done the hospital on this and we
voted for it
when we decided on the three million cap
I understand but I'm not sure what basis
we had for the three million and so I
was going at basis yeah and that's
because it was the the typical average
and we should have notes on that other
questions yes representative ORS thank
you madam chair and thanks for taking my
question so I I missed the number the
last time you did a major computer
upgrade what was the cost it was 3.7
um and that was at
Statewide Enterprise solution so it's a
doit contract it wouldn't be under the
office
um but what we're already discovering
through our internal controls
um projects is that many of the boards
have obligations to license professions
that they have not necessarily been
enforcing and so we have to increase the
number of licensed professions within
that contract and so 3.7 is likely the
ceiling and what year was that that was
just last year okay and we likely will
go out to bid for the procurement of the
next contract within the next year or
two
other questions representative Ames has
is up
yeah just an easy one I
um and maybe it's been answered but the
Senate the bill that's now in the Senate
do you have the number for that yes it's
House Bill 655 it's currently before
Senate Finance 655. thank you
representative fellows
yes thank you madam chair
um can I'm concerned interested in how
to get the fees back in line with where
they should be so I know the 125 percent
is somewhere in statute
does and I know it has something to do
with the court ruling that is that
correct well
um
the court did rule that yes correct um
I'm not sure that the statute is based
on the court ruling or vice versa but um
it applies to all boards whether it be
in a court ruling or
um statute
so
so the requirement
for
125 percent is
per board
or is it per all of oplc Erie is an
interesting point
um
I understand it to be per board
um I think we would see a
um
I think stakeholders would be
um concerned if the interpretation was
at the it only applies to the agency
there continues to be you know a lack of
consensus as to what oplc should be able
to control versus what the boards and I
think the feedback that we've gotten
from a lot of boards and from
um the legislature and from stakeholders
is that the fees of our particular
profession should be used only for that
profession and not for other professions
but follow up follow up so but what
you're telling me is what what the
public wants it's not like it's not
because of the Court ruling I'm just
trying to figure out no what I'm saying
is the ex the existing statute requires
that each profession
um support itself
so profession so that means you have a
board you know
um the cosmetology and The Barbers and
whatever they're all multiple
professions are in one board I'm using
the term profession Loosely I apologize
representative each board is required to
support itself and within each board
they have multiple professions and they
can choose whether they would like to
subsidize certain license tapes or
others and for example nursing has
chosen to subsidize lnas
um and and charge aprns and RNs more
that that is their choice but what what
is improper at least our interpretation
with the advice of doj under the statute
is to say pharmacies which pay two
thousand dollars if they're a mail order
pharmacy have to cover the cost of lnas
because those are two different boards
representative
also doj told you it's okay for
pharmacies to cover some of the costs
for lnas no that's the opposite of what
I said a doj has advised that each board
has to cover its own costs based on
their interpretation of the statute and
we agree with that interpretation so we
we cannot require that Pharmacy for
example just an example subsidize other
professions like helenase and just as
the last part of this is is this process
for determining what the fees should be
for each profession or you know with
within the board are there rules related
to that
so
um our
this has been a long-standing project
um there's a statute that requires us to
seek a stakeholder and board feedback we
began this process back in 2021 that's
what
um led to a modification of Senate Bill
330 actually and created a committee to
study the issue because there were
stakeholder feedback
and then
um
we decided first rather than having
rules in 54 different sets of rules that
we would take the existing statutory and
Regulatory fees and put them in one
document that is currently before jail
car and there's with few minor
exceptions very few modifications to
fees
um and then the next step is going to be
changing the
um how we uh
cover or how we assess our time in the
office and then
redo the allocation of shared costs so
that we can provide boards with their
total costs operating costs for the
biennium so that then we can propose new
fees and we likely will have to do that
fairly soon over the course of a
six-month period
um
in order to make sure that all boards
are are covering their costs and other
boards are not paying way too much
representative
things what court judgment is this new
no it was a Supreme Court case
um 30 40 years yes and I forget the name
one that we've been operating under
correct representative
uh and then the other one is um
they're under the on
hb655
are you given authority to
um on deconstruct
some of the boards under your
purview what do you mean by deconstructs
well on uh end oh no uh
oh no we wouldn't
um no that that has not been proposed
what was proposed in hp2 is to eliminate
certain boards
um I think that was largely taken out
but there's nothing in 655 that would
propose to repeal uh statutes
establishing boards
thank you
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
appreciate it and I would remind folks
to just look back at your notes from the
last bill that we dealt with was very
very similar to this as we go for it
okay any other uh representative Army
could we ask Chris Shea to come and
explain the fiscal note to us
I don't know if he's uh prepared to do
that of what we were talking about
before you showed up but Chris I don't
know if you're aware we're on Senate
Bill 49 right
and
it is quite clear that the lapse to the
general fund at the end of next year
will be will uh disappear and it's 6.5
to 8 million dollars estimate on why is
the
the fiscal note zero zero zero zero zero
thank you for the question for the
record crochet legislative budget
assistant the deputy for the office
um the total revenue being collected
isn't changing as a result of this bill
it's just where the revenue is being
deposited so now it's going to all
remain within the dedicated oplc fund
and that's why in The Narrative we
explain that the general fund wouldn't
get a piece of the revenue that it was
getting under the current law but the
total revenue doesn't change
so that's why it's zeroed at the Top If
we put a negative number there it would
look like there's
Revenue being lost but we're trying to
explain because of the table's
limitations that it's General funds and
other funds that are being impacted and
then in the narrative we explain what
happens
so so that that's the only reason it's
it's a net zero
impact
between for the revenue collected by the
state
uh you open to other questions
and representative fellows oh
thank you madam chair
I apologize would you yield for
representative thank you on on so if
under this bill it's 8 million that
should have lapsed
two million will laps because there's a
three million no the 3 million is the
biennium so 5 million would flaps based
on the language in the bill I believe
none lapses back to the general fund at
this point
so they'd have to
any there's limitations on what they can
have in the fund and there's ways that
the
oplc is expected to expend that Revenue
so they'll they'll have to expend up to
two to five million dollars in the next
year
or reduce licensing and certification
fees right well that's part of expending
on this doesn't seem to be terribly
helpful when they're dealing with what's
in the general fund
all right the fiscal note does have some
limitations when there's a net zero
impact on a funding or an expense
um and that's why the narrative aspect
of it becomes a little bit more
important
yeah and something that a lot of people
don't read
uh I can't help that if they don't read
them the narrative part it's there to
help you
representative Phyllis thank you I have
a question about Capital expenditures
because this bill talks about money
being available to the agency for
Capital expenditures after they pay for
their operating expenditures so
um what is the process for spending
Capital expenditures don't do they what
can you give us a definition of what it
means when as in this bill and what is
the process for
approving an expenditure can it be done
by the agency does it have to be
budgeted does it have to go to the
capital whatever the committee
thank you for the question this fund is
non-lapsing and continually appropriated
to the open oplc
um and within that language
they're allowed to spend the money in
certain ways and so the oplc would
potentially be able to
um spend the money on a capital Project
without needing to come back through the
capital budget process or come back to
fiscal or Finance
because the authority is given to them
to spend from the fund
for those members who have been around
for a while you may may recall back um
probably eight years ago when this
dedicated fund was starting
a previous director wanted to use some
of the fun to pave the parking lot at
their old site and there were some
questions on whether that was allowable
so I don't know if that's part of the
reason for getting this capital
expenditure I heard the director
mentioned that they had computer
projects that they would want to expend
funds on and are expending funds on
um but the way this is structured they
would have that ability to do can you
define the capital what it what
qualifies this capital
I think it's typically thought of as
like the structures and more recently
it's the you start to include your
larger IT projects
you know so if there's a new system
being put in that's been considered a
capital
expense at least in the capital budget
but I would defer to oplc to give you a
better definition of what they
anticipate the term Capital expenditures
might mean here
representative Omi and then we'll go
over there
uh would would they be allowed to if
they could find or build another place
to move into that is slightly less
expensive than the one they're stuck in
now for eight years to spend money to
break the lease and to move
without having to go through capital
budget
so purchasing buildings is a function of
administrative services
so I think that there would be other
processes in place if the
oplc were to want to move and break its
lease and move into a new facility I
think there would be some other
oversights around that
um
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chair
um
taking your point about it's a wash and
the limitations of the fiscal note
isn't it nevertheless pretty much the
bottom line that if
the fund could be generating as much as
eight million dollars over the biennium
and that no longer defaults to the
general fund
and they're required by this bill
to adjust fees downwards as soon as they
hit the three million dollar threshold
the the end result
is this drives a process that reduces
the fees by about five million
I think timing becomes an issue so if
you look at our fiscal note it goes
through 26 so depending on when this
might occur it might be outside that
period so I don't think we would
speculate at this point
how much extra Revenue they would or
wouldn't have to drive down fees
that's relatively new to this version of
the bill
representative liply
thank you
um
I know we talked about the spell and I
know I'm new so some of my questions
might be repeats
um
so to follow up on representative spill
spillsbury's question
um fiscal notes are only looking at
a biennium or a year
they look at the current year you're in
and then three years out okay because it
does seem like the way this is
constructed like by design it reduces
Revenue like that's part of the reason
it's written so it does seem strange
that that that idea cannot be captured
in the fiscal note design that we
currently have
so that might be problematic
thank you for the comment um we look at
our fiscal note every year and try to
come up with ways to address
all different aspects that we run into
um it's very difficult to make
every situation
fit this framework
we try to standardize it so that it's
known and understood so any potential
comments you know we receive that and
we'll try to come up with some solutions
and it may take us a little bit but
agreed I mean it would be
it would be better to have a deeper
analysis on this maybe than what's on
there currently
um but we do have some limitations on
how we can get that done thank you it's
great to learn that this is something
that you do sometimes tweak when when
you have new information so thanks for
sharing that the other question I have
and I know we've discussed thank you I
know we discussed this bill
um before
um
so I I'm sorry to to ask the question
again but if we have an I.T department
and if we have the you know the capital
budget process I guess I'm wondering why
a department needs its own capital
budget
I would defer the question to the oplc
okay so I guess I'm wondering if if
department-wide it seems odd it's not
every single department has its own
capital budget and its own I.T budget
normally those function through a
different process so thank you for the
question I'm learning
we all are learning every day that's why
we keep coming back
representative fellows so just to follow
up on that can you tell us like are
there other agencies who have this kind
of structure where they have non-lapsing
fund and they can buy a new building
without getting any legislative approval
of that
I don't know of any agency that has a
dedicated fund where they could buy a
building
agencies there are a number of dedicated
funds that are continually appropriated
and non-lapsing to an entity either be a
department or a commission or a function
and that those funds can be used based
on what the statute says it can be used
for so in this case the statutes
including Capital expenditures there may
be examples of that I'm not aware of it
off the top of my head
representative only there was the
the
Department of Safety when they needed to
replace the building that was falling
into the Winnipesaukee
you're referencing the e911
yeah
this was back Beyond before that this
was during the Great Recession
I think it was the second building for
the it was the backup building for e911
um no
oh Marine Patrol
I'd have to see how that project came
about
yeah yeah falling in when we decided to
keep the money in the dedicated fund
okay other questions
seeing none thank you for coming up on
this bill I do not just one little one
one little tiny representative so just
in terms of money not be being available
at the beginning of the year to cover
costs of an agency I my understanding is
that if they have an appropriation it
doesn't it's not important that they
don't have any cash right at the
beginning of the year is that true or
does it apply to oplc
so agencies that are funded with other
funds are a dedicated fund because of
cash flow they may go into a red or into
a negative at the start of a fiscal year
but it's anticipated based on
projections that they're going to earn
enough Revenue it'll get caught up that
Comptroller's office and Bureau of
accounts would track that and and as
they earn Revenue repay back the general
fund for paying any costs up front
so so paying the covering the payroll is
not a problem not does not be coming
people will be paid
thank you very much uh Senator Lang did
you have one more thing to add okay
great come on up and then we'll we'll
close this unless if there's anyone else
who's here for setup of 49 please fill
out a pin card for us now
the thing I want to remind the committee
is that the commissioner doesn't have
the authority to spend money on a
capital expenditure without going in
front of the governor and Council so any
contract that was any above five
thousand dollars that they would seek so
the software upgrade which she was
talking about that would be potentially
a 3.7 million dollars there was three
million dollars an account they just
can't go do it without if seeking uh
approval from another body so I just
want to make sure it was clear that
doesn't give her a three million dollar
check to write whenever she wants that
that contract would still have to go in
front of the governor and Council for
and go through that process through
those elected officials
one more question are you open to that
representative just related to that
um it goes to governor and Council after
the agency has done an RFP and so the
governor and council is saying you know
is is this an above board contract or
the you know um
if they put it out to bid where the
procedures fare and where they evaluated
correctly and they
you know dot all the eyes and cross all
the t's in terms of contracts but isn't
it correct that governor and Council
doesn't decide that the agency gets to
purchase something they just look at the
contract to make sure the contract is
good correct so I guess I say that's not
true again the governor would bring it
would have to be put on the agenda so
the governor has to approve the say that
they want this to go forward and and put
it on the council agenda so in by tacit
approval the governor would have to say
that it's a worthwhile project and goes
in front of the executive Council just
because I go an agency goes gets an RFP
for something that nobody wants to do
doesn't mean it's forced to go in front
of the executive Council so again
there's tacit approval by the executive
Council the governor that not only is
the contract process fair and uh and was
a prop appropriate but also is that the
Project's needed
you may want to bring the director up
just to talk about that process a little
bit and she would be much more familiar
with that than myself and probably
Senator Lang with the director will be
able to talk about the governor and
Council process
executive Council
she knows more about the executive
Council yeah the executive agencies
other tend to meet with the exact
executive Council more frequently
okay we well I don't I think there's a
lot more questions that some members
have and I certainly encourage you to go
to the director or whoever you need to
any board member the senator
um you know do your own research on this
take the time we're not going to execute
today
um and take your time on that because we
do have some presentations coming up and
I want to make sure we we don't eat into
that time too much okay okay great thank
you so much and with that we'll close
the public hearing on Senate bill 49.
and we will take a five minute recess
and we will come back and we will listen
to presentations on Revenue updates so
again make sure you get uh the
director's direct contact information if
you have more detailed questions she can
help you
okay let's get started so we don't go
too into lunch time
so as I think we've all seen reported in
the press the Senate found 184 million
dollars more than we found in incoming
revenue and so now we're very curious
where that is
um so we're very pleased to have the
commission of the dra and Chris Shea
back to give us an update good morning
for the record crochet Deputy LBA
um before you you have four documents
you have the dra document that's
probably familiar to most of you
you have a single page long sheet
it's got two giant tables on it
then you have a long page which is just
the difference between the house and the
Senate
and then there's a compare sheet
and then the last thing is a worksheet
again it's familiar the house has used
this type of format
so those are the four documents you'll
have before you the first document I
want to start with is the one
sheet long
and what this document is is the dra
information the range of estimates that
they provided to the house that's on the
left side and then the range of
estimates that they provided to the
Senate which is on the right side
and to the chair's comment that the
Senate found about 184 million dollars
more in Revenue the reason for that is
in your business taxes your meals and
rentals tax you're interested in
dividends tax the base number
that the senate had to use was higher
than what the house had
so that they started at a higher point
than what the house did when they were
doing their estimates
and if you look at the Shaded
um
pieces you'll see that the ranges that
the the department grew the bases are
the same so for instance under the
business taxes row five
they grew the base from zero percent to
two percent
each year that was the same growth that
they provided to the Senate and you'll
see that throughout
the one place that there are some
adjustments would be in the tax law
changes so because you have collected
Revenue through April for the Senate
side the department was able to make
some adjustments to say that we've
accounted for some of those decreases in
Revenue so going forward for instance on
line six instead of 19.6 in fiscal year
2023 for your business tax for the tax
law change it was 17.1 decrease
so I just I just again wanted to put
this in front of you just so you could
see what your ranges were for those
taxes that the dra collects and then
what the ranges were for the Senate
um and again that's really how most of
this growth occurred
because could you just explain what what
tax law change reduce the business
profits tax number
so you had um House Bill 2 from 2021
House Bill 2 credit carryover from 2021.
so these are all things over the three
years that would have impacted um your
your uh revenues again uh 2022 you had
House Bill 1221 which was a rate change
um and then the apportionment for the
nol and Senate Bill 435 in 2022 were all
related to the business taxes and for
each of those dra made an adjustment and
I'll let Lindsay to speak to that if
you'd like good morning Lindsey stuff
commissioner New Hampshire Department of
Revenue
the change
that results from the 19.6 in fiscal
year 23 that we gave you in the house
when you're doing your business tax
estimates compared to the 17.1 million
that we gave to the Senate that is
solely due to the hb2 credit carryover
cap we started to see some refunds
issued as a result of that cap in the
time period between when we gave you
your estimates and when we did the
Senate estimates
thank you
so I I guess for the committee's
purposes I I'd move you to the long
sheet that's multiple pages long
and just kind of walk you through each
of the taxes on the front page each of
the revenues on the front page and where
the adjustments are different
so the longsheet starts with the
House and Senate ways and means general
fund education trust fund estimates
the left side of the sheet you have the
plan number and then the house passed
Revenue
the middle of the sheet you see the
Senate Ways and Means estimates and then
the last three columns are the
differences between the Senate Ways and
Means estimates and the house estimates
right away you can if you go across the
bolded business taxes you can see that
the Senate was 25 million dollars higher
in fiscal 23 47 million dollars higher
in 24 and 41 million dollars higher in
25. this is the bulk of the increase
that we were talking about and again it
has to do with the senate had the
advantage of having the April and March
revenues collected dra was able to do
some work related to that and came up
with some new analyzes on what they
thought
the revenues might be over the next
couple of years which created a higher
base to start from
in terms of projections from that base
the Senate was within the same areas or
ranges as the house you know it wasn't
like the Senate said okay we're going to
grow it by 10 and in fact in some
instances the Senate grew their Base
number a little bit less than the
percentage growth that the house used
when they grew their base
similar thing for meals and rooms as you
recall with meals and rooms it's on a
gross number then you uh
reduce it by the amount that's going to
be transferred to the municipal Revenue
fund and that gives you the net number
that would go to the general fund it
just happened that for the senate in
fiscal year 23 and 24 the number is
320.6 but their gross number was
slightly higher in the second year but
there was more removed for the municipal
Revenue fund
tobacco and liquor there were no excuse
me
tobacco there was a slight change in 25
the the Senate was just under a million
dollars higher there were some
discussion that the some members didn't
believe that it would reduce as steeply
as the house had reduced it but again it
was within less than a million dollars
but other than that fiscal 23 and 24
were the same
liquor there was no change from what the
agency provided to the senate or the
house
the IND is a 10 million dollar increase
in all three years again that has to do
with the base and if you look at the
long sheet the Senate essentially took
the um
what was I going to say sorry
so they went with the low end of the
range that this uh they had on their
sheet
so it was 145 million that's what they
stuck with and then they just grew up by
the 10 million or reduced it by 10
million
so it was exactly 10 million higher than
the house position
insurance tax
so premiums were collected in April
actually be in March and then
adjustments are made in April after all
that had been done the department came
in and said they were 15.3 million
dollars higher than what they
anticipated
um when they were before the house so
you'll see in 23 you see that adjustment
up
for 24 and 25 the reason that there's a
slight difference is that the Senate
questioned the commissioner of a
department of insurance and and said you
were pretty conservative with your
numbers why couldn't we go up slightly
in 24 and 25 and there was an agreement
to go up by the million dollars each
year
the agency felt that was reasonable
communication Services tax
again the base changed slightly so
you'll see some of the growth that the
um
the senate had over the house
they did hold it flat almost flat all
three years it was 30.3 and 23 and then
30 million and 30 million and 24.25
. if you need to jump in at any point
feel free okay
really
so I asked the question now when we're
done oh sure would you be open to a
question now yeah should representative
Schaumburg on on the insurance
that the Senate said they just requested
was that backed up by any economic
factors by the insurance department so
so the insurance department you know
testified that they tend to use a
conservative approach to estimating
their revenues
so they were questioned as to why
couldn't it be a little bit higher if
you're being conservative why not be a
little bit higher
and and they agreed that it could be
slightly higher
um
so for moving down to the real estate
transfer you'll see it's a decrease from
the house position again the base was
lower for the real estate transfer and
23 than it was for the house
yes representative Southworth
Stratford County our Register of Deeds
has warned us that really was a rough
period fortunately we found some ways to
make up the funds but there was a pretty
large hit just for our County
you're talking on real estate transfer
taxes yes okay thank you
you're seeing that Statewide basically
and you'll see the senate had a you know
13.5 million dollars less than the house
and then five and five and 24.25
reflecting some of what they heard in
their hearings on the revenue
court fines and fees you'll see a slight
adjustment down the agency
um many of you know Donna Raymond from
the courts she re-looked at her figures
and and came in slightly less than what
she had presented to the house
so you'll see it's a 200 000 adjustment
down in 23 500 024 and five eight
hundred thousand and twenty five and
much of that has to do with some of the
The Plea by mail related revenue and I
think she testified to that before you
that it's really hard to project how
where that's going to land because
there's been changes on how who collects
that but also with covid and what the
courts were doing some of the flow of
that Revenue
um
uh Securities Revenue there was no
difference between the house and the
senate had
no difference in the beer tax
the other Revenue you'll see a slight
adjustment upward in 23 so now that they
um again are through the month of April
the department
um controller and then the treasurer had
a better sense of where we were going to
land with some of those other revenues
including interest revenue and the
abandoned property Revenue so they were
up by 2.3 over the house but slightly
down in um 24 and 25 100 000 each year
again it's just based on their
forecasting of some of those revenues
the lottery Revenue
you're going to see it was up in 23
the house had 170 million point eight
the commission came in at 180 million
um and for 23.
similar to Insurance
um the the director of uh the Lottery
Commission indicated that they budget
their revenue pretty conservatively
so the committee challenged them to
maybe increase it slightly and the
commission agreed with the CFO
uh after looking at you know some of his
projections agreed it could go up by 2
million and 24 and a million and 25.
representative Southworth thank you
um in talking with the lottery the
different forms of gambling we've been
hearing room for growth in our
conversations but it doesn't look like
the budget really showed room for growth
is that just uh an unknown
so if you recall when the director for
the Lottery Commission spoke with you he
talks about a lot of unknowns with the
revenues Associated you need a couple of
big Powerball type games and that the
billion dollar lottery or prize is is
becoming old people want to see
something higher so the revenue
generation is is slowing down slightly
in addition you know you've got other
games that are opening up and and he
still hadn't fully realized the benefits
or the impacts of on each other so he
hadn't talked about a conservative
approach to his revenues in the out
years
um I I think the Senate pushed him a
little bit more than the house did on
that aspect of being conservative in the
two out years
representatively
I turned it off instead of on I
apologize sorry
um
so just to restate to make sure I
understand this correctly it sounds like
the Senate based on the first quarter
revenues of this year
um for FY 2023 pushed up their estimates
is that correct so you have nine months
of Revenue collected through April and
based on what you've collected
right so it's not just the first quarter
it's actually nine months it's nine
months so you have a good sign some of
your Revenue collections you see most of
that occur in April like your IND
So based on some of these estimates that
came in the senate had a better position
in terms of their projections than this
the house did if you recall the house
you didn't really have March estimates
or April estimates right so they're um
estimating
2023 really with only three months left
right okay and then 2024 2025 numbers
look lower because like us
they're expecting the economy to slow
down a little bit from 23.
yes okay yes thank you representative
plan yes thank you thank you for taking
my question when did the senate pass its
Revenue estimate how long ago
last Wednesday okay so there's no
updates from dra to have us further
tweak and thank you no d8 but dra is
here to if there was questions that were
Beyond me which wouldn't take much
yeah and again we're always the house is
always a little bit of a disadvantage
because the two major Revenue months are
March and April and we didn't have that
information so thank you uh
representative Ames
thank you and thank you
um for being here and helping us out
um
I'm looking at the business tax
uh and the net revenue and the amounts
projected by
uh by the Senate ways and Mains and um
essentially they're sort of halfway
between your high and low as I get it I
mean that's rough but something like
that
my question is to to you for to dra and
uh
uh whether since you met with us because
these are still the same it's the same
spread
factors that you used before whether
you've uh a lot has happened in the
economy in the last two months or it
appears to have happened or you know
we're all looking at it and wondering
what's going on
and um predictions are as usual you know
impossible to make but we make them
nonetheless and um
and so you're still you're hanging in
there with zero percent and two percent
um yeah in both years uh can you just
all right
I just fiddle with my hands and it
yeah sure the factors that go into the
zero to two percent range
um so
I will counter your statement of a lot
has happened in the economy in the last
few months to a lot of conversations
about the economy have happened in the
last few months although looking at
our business tax revenues
we're not seeing a lot of changes
necessarily in the economy estimates for
April were 23 ahead of the prior April
um returns and extensions performed well
up about five percent from the prior
year
um and our tax notice revenue is still
strong so I think those factors are kind
of leading us to that two percent where
we're still seeing strong revenues
in the business taxes but it is those
conversations about the economy I think
that are causing us to lower that growth
to that essentially stagnant growth at
zero percent and the things that we're
thinking about there are inflation
um it seems to be calming down a little
bit
um and so it's not climbing at the same
rate that it had in the prior year
we are keeping an eye on employment
numbers employment is still strong and
the the expectations coming out of the
Employment Security Department are that
we're still doing quite well in terms of
employment when that number starts to
grow is when we kind of start we'll
start to get a little bit more nervous
about where the economy is heading
I think though at this point the biggest
unknown is the debt ceiling and what is
going to happen there if nothing happens
there these numbers would look very
different
um but that is is an unknown and
something that we can't really factor in
at this point but it's something that
we're watching
um so
the zero to two percent like I said is
really the result of our Revenue numbers
still look really strong
um but we know that there are at least
some cooling factors in the economy and
that we shouldn't expect the continued
growth that we've seen and we should
what we're feeling is a reduction in the
growth but not necessarily a turn
negative and so that's why the bottom is
at zero
representative Mommy
thank you we have two factors coming
into play starting in 24. on credit
carry forward you mentioned
um there's some changes initial changes
in it and what were they so those were
the same for fiscal 24 the Senate
estimates use the same numbers that you
had which was we're anticipating
a two uh 13 and a half million dollar
reduction in revenues or due to the CCO
cap in 24 and a 3.8 million reduction in
25 those numbers didn't change from the
house to the Senate no what I said
changed was fiscal 23 impact
because we have started to see some
refunds in fiscal 23. so the number that
that no that's fine the number that the
house was given in fiscal 23 for the
impact of cco's
was 11 million
and when we presented to the Senate we
reduced that number to eight and a half
million because we had seen some refunds
starting to happen so it was only for
fiscal 23 that we modified that number
for the Senate
so you don't one of the fears is that
if we head towards recession that more
on people are going to upfront their uh
taking back what they've got in the
treasury and you haven't seen any
discussion even of that yet we have not
and that decision is really a business
by business decision some will choose to
bring the cash back because they want
the cash back in their own accounts
others when the economy is looking like
it is heading to into some sort of a
Slowdown or a recession they will leave
their CCO with us to make sure that they
have enough money with us to make their
payments and not occur additional
penalties and interest so it really is a
business by business decision
could could I the second Factor on the
single sales Factor we are losing
a number of very large businesses that
sell outside the state produce and sell
outside the state on
have few
do you feel fairly confident that we're
going to be able to replace those with
companies that we haven't yet had much
or any from that are going to be selling
inside our elderly state
the short answer to that question is yes
I don't feel like businesses moving out
of the state or only selling outside of
the state
um will will not be at least mostly made
up by sales into the state for which we
didn't
um
we didn't count or get as much
apportionment from previously so we
cannot fully analyze that because that
change is still relatively new but again
the number the revenue numbers look
strong so I'm not seeing it causing a
drastic impact at this point on our
revenues
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chair I have two
questions if I may okay
work session so it's a little more fluid
for questions thank you
so the difference in timing of the house
review in the Senate view is clear and
the fact that March and April revenues
continued to exceed particularly on the
business and m r
that's all clear
so I don't find that at all surprising
that it it's that it's reflected in FY
23. I guess falling further on
representative Ames line of inquiry
what
what would give us hope that a recession
isn't virtually inevitable given the
fed's policy
to
break things down
uh and and why would we ex even if we're
seeing
uh Stronger revenues in in 23 years we
close out the final months why would we
expect that to be repeated in 24 and 25.
so the the fed's policy has been in
place for quite a while now we've been
they've been raising interest rates
consistently for over a year
and we haven't seen that yet result in a
recession
I think a lot of people expected that we
would have seen a recession by now and
we haven't
so there is a part of me that hopes and
believes that the FED is it being at
least somewhat successful in cooling the
economy without sending us into a
recession I think what makes this a
little bit different than
prior instances of raising of interest
rates is that there is a fair amount of
money still in the economy as a result
of the federal government infusion of
Revenue during covid and so that may be
helping to bolster what would have
otherwise caused a recession as a result
of the interest rates going up
um business taxes
fiscal year to date
through April were
through April were five and a half
percent ahead of Prior year
so I don't anticipate that growth to
continue which is how we kind of get to
the zero to two I believe when the house
did
their estimates you had a slightly
negative growth before the tax law
changes and then the Senate took a one
percent growth took the middle of our
range for 23 to 24. so just further on
the first question yeah
I think that's an outstanding
explanation and I accept that anything
that we try to project is just purely
speculative
but I do work I'm less optimistic
because I do think that it's the stated
intention of the Fed
to
yes they've been trying for a year to
get a reaction and they haven't gotten
it so they're basically saying we're
going to keep doing this until something
breaks sure that's that's my just to
close out that first
second question
um I see uh in the entries at the bottom
of the page the changes to current law
uh the best item there
is the acceleration of the IND repeal
and since there's no action yet by the
Senate
um that magnifies the uh the difference
in fy25
but I'm just wondering status since I
haven't been following where the
Senate's at if they've just adopted
these Revenue estimates last Wednesday
where are they at with the budget Bill
and are there tax law or tax rate
changes that are likely to come forward
in the Senate budget bill
So currently the finance committee
Senate finance committee is in the
process of making some decisions they'll
complete decisions potentially by next
Friday or the following Tuesday
they still have some outstanding issues
that they're discussing and and still
debating so there's not much I can say
at this point there has been no action
taken on the IND
um
suspect yet fair enough then would it be
correct to say that
the Senate's actions such as they may
turn out to be are not yet reflected in
this chart and may close that apparent
Gap a bit
that's correct
my hands up over here the first
representative fellows so I'm sorry if I
could just so really what you want to
focus on is that the top part of that I
put the bottom part on this just to
remind you what the house did so as we
move forward through the Senate phase if
you're paying attention you'll say oh
they did the same thing or they didn't
and then you can make some adjustments
for yourself
kind of on the same topic so I just
wanted more clarification on those
changes to current law or are they
proposed changes to current law and then
I see that there's something that
doesn't have anything to do with Revenue
total revenue but for the education
between the general fund and the
education trust fund that some of the
bet money was being moved out out of the
general fund right into the trust fund
what so explain what that was
So currently the it is proposed it's the
house position it's the house proposed
change it's the current law that you're
seeing reflected there
those changes are shown on the Surplus
statement as you recall when I came
before you
um earlier this season
um any current Law changes would be
reflected on the the Surplus statement I
carry them here just so you can see an
Apples to Apples once all decisions are
made
um because this is the general fund
education trust fund combined you don't
see the um
the difference on where BPT b-e-t is
going for the education trust funded
general fund that I'll be showing on the
next two pages so I haven't gotten there
yet but there's a piece in House Bill
too that would change how
um the business taxes are allocated to
the education trust fund and the
um general fund okay so that switch is
in the house version of hb2 that is
correct okay and these are all things
that were in the house version because
we don't have the hb2 that's correct
they haven't finished that work yet
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question I share some of Representative
spillsbury's concerns we haven't hit a
recession yet
but it's the last inflation or monthly
inflation rate was five five and a half
percent somewhere in that range well
above the two percent
Target that feds and I don't buy the two
percent I'd make it zero but they have a
two percent upper limit Target
uh so they're going to continue to raise
interest rates maybe at a slower Pace
because of the impact on banking but as
they do that it's eventually going to
have an impact I one would think it may
be delayed because uh
of a federal money sloshing around from
all the federal stimuli but that's
frying up so you you share that Center
but do you think are more optimistic
than I am no I I do share that sentiment
and so I think what it comes down to is
does that impact on interest rates and
hopefully lowering inflation cool the
growth or result in negative growth
and what we what we believe at this
point is that it's going to cool that
growth from the five purse five and a
half almost six percent that we're
seeing now
um the growth over the prior year
was at six percent so we have seen a
little bit of a cooling of that growth I
think that will continue and it will
accelerate it will that we went from six
and percent year-over-year growth we're
currently at five and a half percent
your over your growth I very much think
that will cool hence the zero to two
percent we are just at this point not
predicting that it will go negative
and we could be wrong
but it and and to your point though the
timing of you know potential Federal
monies drying up
um
the the timing of when you know if and
when we see really employment issues in
all sectors employment issues at the
moment tend to be in certain industries
you hear of you know Tech layoffs but
then you hear of other industries that
you know will hire anybody because they
need bodies when that employment issue
starts to become more even me
when that employment issue starts to
become if and when that becomes more
broad-based or the impacts to Industries
become more broad-based and we see the
impacts affecting every business that's
when I think we might go negative
um and again as we've talked about
previously
New Hampshire doesn't tend to our
revenues in a recession do not fall as
far as other states we don't see you
know a drastic decrease in revenues we
don't fall as far but we take longer to
recover so think of like the Nike Swoosh
right it's a little bit of a drop and
then a longer recovery so I think that
historical perspective is factoring into
our estimates as well
representative Amy
at ncsl on them I think four years ago
on and I haven't been able to follow it
up since there was a very good
analyst who mentioned in response to a
question of mind that there the feds
are once a year on take a survey of all
of the bank accounts in America and they
uh
in the spring as I recall but you don't
get the results until the fall and they
analyze it by income level I don't know
if they'd all they recall if they also
do it by uh industrial sector or
whatever that would be harder because
they're mixing up all of the accounts
not just the individual accounts
and
um I wonder if we could get a copy of
last year's in the year before even
knowing what it had been moving between
21 and 22 would be some kind of
of help on one of my theories and his
actually was that that the money would
die out of the accounts of lower income
people first and then gradually come up
to a level where you were talking people
with real money or corporations with
real money
we both took a note of that so between
the two of us hopefully we can track
down that information for you
thank you madam chair
um I agree with the idea that um
the FED is going to continue raising to
get to two percent we don't know where
that's going to land but this morning
and previous to this morning I've read
articles about how there's a continuing
credit
crunch that's that's starting to grow
where people are the other thing that's
possibly leveling this out right now is
people using their credit cards and with
credit card balances continuing to
increase at some point they can't
increase anymore and so the the multiple
factors of the FED uh stated goal of
continuing to raise rates until they hit
two percent inflation coupled with
the credit card crunch that seems to be
increasing
um
could also could you know would you
agree that that could also cause a
Slowdown
I do agree and the other tax type to
consider with that is the meals and
rentals tax because that's how do you
pay when you go out to dinner at a
restaurant right most people play with
your credit card how do you pay for
hotel stays credit cards so that is
another tax that we would keep an eye on
with respect to that specific issue
Philip
not completely Apollo but an additional
concern for the economy is that I as a
landlord over the past couple years have
raised my rents because of increasing
costs but one of the things I'm seeing
is tenants are starting to max out on
what they can afford
that doesn't stop the cost side for me
to keep increasing but
you know I can't necessarily increase
the rents anymore So eventually that's
another factor and and not just
landlords but you know any sort of uh
store that's raising rates uh raising
prices at some point the consumer just
can't afford it anymore agreed I think
we talked a little bit about that in
this committee as well when you were
doing your meals and rentals estimates
right inflation is going to drive prices
up costs are going to increase
restaurants are going to increase prices
which increases the tax since the tax is
a function of the price until the point
where either restaurants can't
increase the price anymore because
consumers just won't pay it the supply
and demand doesn't work
so effectively that could decrease m r
taxes coming in and business profits
taxed correct right okay other yes
representative Schamberg or no
Southworth thank you
be partly propaganda but there have been
several articles from people in that
industry saying that their bookings are
way up and they're expecting one of the
biggest summers in many many years
especially from people coming from
Canada and so on so I know there's a lot
of information it does seem kind of
contradictory I think there was
um a release yesterday from the division
of travel and tourism expecting four and
a half million dollars in Revenue to you
know New Hampshire businesses this
summer based on overnight stays so that
it is expected that people will continue
to travel here and stay here during the
hearings in the Senate we also heard
about the solar eclipse that is going to
happen in April of next year and that
bookings up north are already almost at
capacity so if you haven't yet I would
encourage you to to make a booking if
you'd like to view that
um and then we also in the Senate talked
a little bit about the presidential
primary as well with respect to m r and
the fact that that can can generate some
hostel stays and some meals and meals
consumed drinks as well during that
season so there it's all factors that
need to be considered and I think the
Senate did take that into account when
estimating their growth rate for m r um
thinking that some of these more special
events May help bolster m r
um as we go into the next two years
representative yes the m r
people raised their rent rates because
to cover their costs that helps seminar
correct and we're coming out of a
post-covered lockdown essentially so
people are traveling your right and
spending money on meals but could you
see that ending in other words they
won't stop going out but to slow down
in all honesty I thought we would have
seen that already and and we haven't
um and so the way we kind of refer to it
at the dra when we're talking about it
is kind of the new normal for m r we did
expect a bump in m r Revenue coming out
of covid but I expected that to kind of
decrease pretty quickly right everybody
catches up on their vacations
um you know realizes how much they like
to eat out they go out to dinner quite a
bit but then they would kind of resort
to their old habits but they we seem to
have sustained a higher level of m r
than we saw pre-pandemic one of the
things that was mentioned during the
Senate hearings that may be driving up
that Revenue that may start to tail off
is the pent-up demand for special events
weddings business conferences large
Gatherings of that sort there was a lot
of pent-up demand for that that may have
carried through the past few years that
may be trailing off where you don't have
you know weddings four or five nights a
week because you had two years of people
you know trying to get their events
rescheduled so that may tail off a bit
representative only
yes on I think it was about 10 years ago
that I looked at the m r rates for March
April May versus I'm not March April May
but around the time the primary had
happened and
and outside of that time and didn't see
any correlation
I'm not sure that it results in a
noticeable increase in m r When
comparing to this to other months but I
think more my point was it might help to
kind of sustain m r in a period where it
otherwise might be declining so maybe
not a noticeable impact in normal times
but it may help keep m r at a higher
rate when it otherwise would decline
representative leapley
thank you
um I'm looking at the differences column
in FY 2024 and it looks like a lot a
large number
is the business taxes and m r right so
I'm wondering
um
what happens
if
the economy does slow down and those
numbers look let's say they look like
the 2023 numbers
and
the IND tax change passes
um
what would happen to our Revenue
situation as a state
so
I will mention that for business taxes
in m r
for the house for business taxes your
growth rate from 24 to 25 was just under
minus one percent you anticipated a
decline in the tax
and then 24 to 25 you anticipated a one
and a half percent growth
the senate had a one percent growth from
23 to 24 and a one percent growth from
24 to 25. so the house was a little more
pessimistic 23 to 24 and a little more
optimistic 24 to 25.
for m r you anticipated a one and a half
percent growth from 23 to 24 and the
Senate anticipated two percent
you anticipated two and a half percent
from 24 to 25 and the Senate anticipated
one and a half so your amounts are
almost flipped
so I think over the biennium you're
fairly consistent in your growth rates
just maybe disagree on which year is
going to be better than the other okay
in terms of the impact IND as Chris
mentioned that would show on the Surplus
statement
um and so it would be kind of accounted
for after you agree on your Revenue
estimates
what I think your question might be if
your revenues don't come in as forecast
what happens
and essentially the answer is the
expense side would need to be reduced if
you did if you budgeted to zero but we
don't know that that's going to occur
yet there may be um
not every dollar will be budgeted right
again the Senate you the house didn't
budget everything there was some money
that was going to go to the rainy day
fund the Senate will have a plan that
will deposit some money to the rainy day
fund so there's a little bit of buffer
in the Surplus I don't know what that
number will be okay I I think what I'm
thinking of is is everyone is kind of
thinking through what might happen with
the economy and and
these numbers
um leave a lot of things out right all
the expenses are left out and I think
the result if these numbers go down more
than we expect is that you know more
people would be homeless more people
would be unemployed more people would
need more services so it kind of Demands
our expenses go up but if our revenues
go down our expenses necessarily go down
and I'm not sure again because I'm new
how the rainy day fund
is drawn on don't we have to have like a
certain
uh need before we can draw on that
that's correct
so there's a process there's a process
that at the end of the biennium if
there's a shortage in the revenue
compared to your expenses then money can
be drawn from the rainy day fund in the
interim it would be up to the executive
side to manage budgets and to what
you've seen are budget reductions in the
past when there's been an economic
slowdown the governors have had
executive orders where they have said to
agencies you need to reduce your spend
and then they come before fiscal to get
that adopted
so so there's processes in place to look
at that the the executive side will
monitor their expenses if revenues
aren't coming in
um you know at the end of the biennium
if there's a negative because revenues
weren't there compared to the
expenditures and the rainy day fund
would be drawn against to pay for that
representative
this has to do with the business profits
tax and I'm not going to question the
numbers uh necessarily this is a test of
how vulnerable we are to changes though
a Black Swan events
are we dependent on business profits tax
for a couple of major multinationals
creating most of it so let's say a GE
falling apart after over the last four
years if we had a major one like that if
it collapsed how how would we be
affected
so that's a good question
um as we've shown in the triangles that
we produce
um the majority of business tax revenue
comes from a few multinational
corporations however I will note each
year it's not necessarily the same few
um so again during we'll use the
pandemic as an example the multinational
corporations that may have been in the
tip of that triangle before the pandemic
were not the same corporations in the
tip of the triangle during the pandemic
because certain industries fared better
than others
so again it kind of goes back to
we
are in an okay place
even if there are certain industries
that are being impacted by various
things where we start to worry is when
every industry is feeling the impact of
a downturn or a recession if you have an
industry like during covid like tourism
that was not performing as well but you
had another industry like healthcare
that was performing well they can kind
of offset each other but you are correct
that that the
that the tip of that triangle tends to
be large multinational corporations
um and so if they are impacted we could
see an impact to that portion of the
revenue
representative fellows thank you
um one of the things that we've seen
over the last couple years in terms of
inflation has been rental
um costs so I assume that
landlords pay business profits tax in
some cases
do you do you see any indication that
the rising rental prices are showing
additional Revenue coming into the state
from that sector
we have not analyzed that sector in
particular
um but it just with any sector to the
extent that prices are higher whether
it's rent whether it's meals whether
it's the price of widgets that you sell
to the extent that prices are higher and
that is hitting your profits we will see
an increase in business profits tax
follow-up is it any
um income from rental of residential
you know Apartments
um is that a very big sector at all in
terms of the revenues coming from
business profits I would say that's not
a terribly large sector of the I don't I
wouldn't want to venture I guess but I
would say it's not
a terribly significant industry when you
look at all of the business profits
taxes representative almi
thank you two things
sorry the the
um if a if large businesses pull out of
the state or aren't selling into the
state the way we are now on
it
affects our the ones that actually were
in our state on also do not are not
paying as much bet
or any bet
so we we really have to look at the
effect from you too it seems to me on if
we get into that kind of position we're
losing bet as well as BPT
but um
I can't remember what the other one she
brought up was
just met him chair I didn't if we could
um finish going through the document
just so I can get you to the end of it
before I'm assuming you guys are going
to try to break it noon but I can keep
you longer if you'd like we would love
to break at noon and we would love for
you to continue your presentation
so just to finish up on the first page
you had the tobacco settlement was where
we left off you'll notice that the
amount that came in in April was 44.6
Million when you did your estimates the
Attorney General at that time thought 42
and you'll see that the plan amount was
36.3 amount 36.3 million so you can see
how volatile that that tobacco
settlement Revenue can be so for the out
years the the Senate just took the same
estimate of 40 million and 38.5 million
that was provided by the department
the utility property tax the Senate was
slightly less than the house
again it was just some of the um the
ranges the bases that were a little bit
lower
um as it was presented to the Senate
than it was for the house
Statewide education property tax the
same across the board that's fairly easy
straightforward we were hoping for
debate but there was none
Medicaid recoveries you're going to see
an adjustment there the house had 2.6
million the Senate came away with 3.4
million to date 3.1 million has been
collected in recovery so the Senate felt
3.4 based on the plan amount was
appropriate
and then looking at the 10-year
um
Trend that was reported in the AK for
the Senate agreed that they should bump
it up to 3 million in 24 and 25.
and that's why you see the difference
there
so that gets you to the bottom line that
where you see the 63.2 million 66.1 and
the 55 million over the three years
which is the 184.3 million dollar
increase
so again that's your general fund
education trust funds we've already gone
over the bottom portion which is the
changes to proposed changes to current
law the Senate hasn't completed that
work so there's nothing to show on their
side of that you can see what the house
had agreed to
um on the on the left side if you flip
to page two I'm not going to go through
every line but I wanted to just point
out
uh representative fellow said the
question about the the splits for the
business tax and the um going to the
education trust fund into the general
fund and that would be the second and
third rows under changes to current law
and you'll see the um
general fund split for the house was
77.5 percent
for both those for the bet the
governor's proposal had been 65 percent
yeah
same type of thing on the next page
which is the education trust fund
again you'll see the um the splits there
at the 22 and a half percent again the
Senate has made no decision on what they
want to do with this aspect of House
Bill too
then if I can take you to page four
the top part of that is the highway fund
estimates
so the road toll was identical for the
um house and the Senate there were some
slight adjustments in the motor vehicle
fees presented by the department of
safety and that's what you see
um a 0.3 increase in fiscal year 23 and
then a 1.2 million dollar increase in 24
and 25.
um and then for the miscellaneous it
stayed at 200 000.
and again the miscellaneous is um
Revenue that's generated by the
Department of Transportation
mainly through the sale of surplus
buildings and um equipment
excuse me land and equipment
so if there's no questions on the
highway fund I'll bump you down to the
Fish and Game fund
again there was no changes to the
licenses the 9.8 million in all three
years for both the house and the Senate
there were some adjustments in the other
Revenue
one of the um one of the adjustments
related to interest Revenue the fish and
game fund
um is allocated Revenue when the
treasurer is able to gather that so not
all funds are portioned out a piece of
the interest when they get that it will
go typically to the general fund however
the fishing game fund has been seen
about forty thousand dollars a month in
Revenue related to the interest so the
Senate um accounted for that in the
three years as well as in the um
24 and 25 the fish and game department
had
its unrefunded road toll and unrefunded
Marine road tolls
um
we're at a flat level of 800 900
respectively but in the last few years
they've been collecting a million
million one
um when questioned the department agreed
to bump each of those up by a hundred
thousand dollars
so it was a two hundred thousand dollar
bump up in each year related to those
unrefunded road tolls so that's the
difference in the fishing game area
so I just wanted to make sure we got to
that
the last document which I won't go
through but it is the worksheet
um
I think the benefit of that if if you're
interested is if you flip the page four
you can see what revenues were in fiscal
year 22. you can see what was the plan
versus what was actually collected then
you can see what the plan is for fiscal
year 23 and then you can see what the
governor
the house
what the agencies high and lows were for
the Senate and then what the Senate
estimates are so it kind of gives you a
One-Shot look at you know the various
stages of the the revenue estimating
so again I won't go through all that
because it's really summarized you know
on the sheet we just went through
I think that again the reason that uh
the chair invited us here today was to
kind of go through what the Senate
provided to give you some information as
the for the committee so as you think
about
um going forward if there is a committee
a conference or some other action that
might be needed in terms of revenues you
at least have some Base information to
go by all the documents that the
agencies provided are on our website for
both the house and the Senate
um all the agency presentations were
streamed on the YouTube so if you went
to the Senate ways and means you'd be
able to watch certain agencies if you
wanted to hear what they testified to
um so happy to answer any additional
questions or go over anything but just
wanted to make sure we got you to the
end because sometimes we miss the
highway and fishing game
thank you so much representative Platt I
just wanted to say thank you for the
presentations and all the hard work you
do to give the House and Senate some
basis to estimate really appreciate it
representative Army yes and we haven't
gone through
the gra presentation but since it's very
similar to the one that we had before we
can probably handle it on our own
correct that is
um the dra presentation that's in front
of you that is what we presented to the
Senate it looks just like the
presentation we gave to you the only
thing that changed was the high and low
estimates for fiscal 23. so the only
thing as Chris already mentioned that
changed in that presentation was the
high and low estimates for fiscal 23 the
growth rates for 24 and 25 for every tax
remained the same
and Chris has also summarized that
presentation within his
um worksheets as well but if you wanted
to
I had trouble sleeping and you wanted to
look at something that might help
and the reason why you changed your
range is because the actual revenue is
coming in in March and April were higher
exactly that's a great point so we go
through the same exercise for the Senate
as we did for you we look at
year-to-date revenues we run a few
different scenarios to estimate out the
remainder of the year and then we
analyze those scenarios to see which
ones we think are actually the most
likely to happen and then we present
those as our high and low ranges so yes
it's just an update to year-to-date
revenue and then running the scenarios
thank you very much any other questions
comments discussion yes representative
Olney I'd I'd asked about the bank
account
on analysis the FED does but
um we might be able to get a little bit
more up-to-date material on what's
happening to the credit cards
and it'd be useful I think to get an
idea about how nervous we are about the
recession
which is the big question that none of
us can answer
and I've been talking about for eight
years I think it is now so so
representative Almy are you asking the
commissioner to come back to us with
that if that's or to send it to us yeah
if you have any articles or information
that you could share that'd be helpful
um at this point we probably wouldn't
invite any outside speakers
this is something we want to keep our
eye on obviously especially when the
budget comes back to us we get to see
that uh
I thought of another question
any other questions from the committee
yep
so once the Senate finishes up um
the budget side of it and we know what's
in house bill 2. I'll update the long
sheets so you'll see on the bottom what
the proposed current Law changes are so
you'll get an email at some point
um probably at the beginning of June
that would tell you what the changes are
that they're proposing to the taxes or
other Revenue impacts the other question
I had was when would you have a good
idea on the May revenues
very early June well we will have those
May doesn't tend to be a large Revenue
month
um it's actually one of the lowest out
of the whole year June is the next month
unfortunately that we see the largest
amount of Revenue coming in
um so you'll get the revenue Focus like
you always do at the beginning of of
June for the month of May you get our
daily reports that we send out but I'll
make sure to mention or send a separate
email if there's anything indicative or
anomalous or anything in the May
revenues that I think you should pay
attention to but otherwise it should
just be a pretty standard month but I'll
flag anything if it if I see it
representative Phyllis um yes um because
my printer
won't do these
I'm wondering wondering since since my
printer won't at home won't do these is
where can we pick one up maybe
when you do the new ones oh you just let
me know if you need a hard copy and I'll
make it available at the office okay
thank you
okay great thank you so much we really
appreciate the update and uh folks a
friendly reminder that this Thursday is
a session so we'll see you all there
starts at 10. and then plan on at the
moment plan on next Tuesday and then the
following Tuesday that will come back
and do more work
thank you
somewhere around the 9 30 or 10 I I did
it a little earlier than I expected
today because I wanted to make sure we
left enough time for them so
all right thank you